foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 7122
object class safe
special containment procedures
scp-7122 is to be stored in a secure
safe inside a standard containment room
said room is to have two armed guards
posted outside of it and is only able to
be accessible by level 3 staff or higher
any access to
scp-7122's containment room is to be
reported to the site director
immediately who can initiate a lockdown
if deemed necessary it is thus
recommended that the director be
informed before accessing
scp-7122's containment room as
scp-7122 is an inanimate object that
needs to be handled for anomalous
effects to occur there is no threat of
it breaching containment by itself
however the department of intelligence
has assessed that there is a possibility
that the item may be an object of
interest for hostile groups of Interest
in case of a containment breach the
entire wing of site 717 containing
scp-7122 is to initiate a lockdown with
all light as well as Internet and
intranet access being cut off
immediately in order to prohibit
utilization of
scp-7122's anomalous effects Foundation
staff within the compromised area are to
be advised not to use any source of
light for the entire duration of the
lockdown the only Personnel allowed to
access the locked down section of site
717 in case of a Containment Breach is
the on-site tactical response team upon
recontainment all electronical devices
capable of storing digital data and
media as well as scp-7122 are to be
investigated for any instances of dot
Nao files only after all results have
turned out negative Personnel are to be
released from Lockdown and both internet
and internet access is to be turned back
on
description
scp-7122 is a Nikon brand d3500 DSLR
camera serial number with a standard 18
to 55 millimeter kit lens
scp-7122's anomalous effects manifest
when it is used to photograph a person
upon taking a picture and image file in
the format dot ano is created said files
can be viewed without any special
software on all common media devices
going to the metadata will seemingly
reveal nothing out of the ordinary
however instead of displaying
information about the files such as file
name or the time date and location of
its creation such information will
instead be displayed about the subject
depicted in the photograph additionally
a field can be found at the bottom of
the window saying further properties
investigation of these properties will
open up a separate window with a
sporadically expanding seemingly
nonsensical and random array of numbers
and letters it is theorized that the
extent of these properties directly
correlates to the subject's age and
experiences although most of the dot ano
files ranges from 175 kilobytes to 3.5
megabytes the average amount of data
found within the further properties
section is estimated to be around one
petabyte all Foundation efforts to
decode set data have so far proven
unsuccessful
further anomalous effects have become
apparent when the files are altered or
deleted when a DOT ano file is inserted
into video editing software and a spoken
audio track is combined with said file
the subject in the photograph will
initiate motion matching the spoken
tracks while the recorded voice will
instantly change as well to match the
voice of the depicted subject however
tests have shown that the person in the
photo is the only one affected by this
meaning that the rest of the picture
will not initiate any sort of movement
deletion of a DOT Nao file will result
in the immediate termination of the
subject in the picture tests have shown
that this effect only applies to the
pictured person Even In Crowd scenarios
if no specific subject exists in such a
picture no anomalous effects will
manifest the foundation is not yet been
able to determine the medical cause of
death of the test subjects
scp-7122's effects also apply to various
animals see Tesla dogs and can be
avoided by creating a copy of the
original Nao file in advance deleting
the metadata of a DOT Nao file will not
result in the subject's death
however the subject will become
unresponsive and cease almost all motor
functions in a catatonic State tests
have shown that subjects affected by
this are not incapable of actions like
walking but rather simply do not do so
for most of the time
discovery
scp-7122 came to the foundation's
attention after a sudden rise of
unexplained deaths and reported cases of
anonymous blackmail in gustavsburg
Sweden and the surrounding area the SCP
Foundation dispatched two local field
agents to investigate the situation in
cooperation with Swedish law enforcement
agencies agent Roland Jansen and agent
Carl Berg subsequently managed to deduce
that the cases were linked to Jen's
Eklund a local amateur photographer and
videographer and drug addict agents
Jansen and Berg were ordered to
investigate the property under the guise
of an electrical inspection following a
short unrelated blackout in gustavsburg
after they were able to determine that
the camera was the object of Interest it
was given the official designation of
scp-7122 and a tactical response team
was dispatched to recover the item under
the pretext of a drug raid
Jen's Eckland was fatally wounded during
said rain after using
scp-7122 to kill two tack rep operators
test logs
test 7122 A1
subject d-9669
description and results subject was
photographed using
scp-7122 photograph was deleted d-9669
died on the spot
test 7122 O2
subject d-9671
description and results subject was
photographed in absolute Darkness using
scp-7122 photograph was deleted no
change noted on subject
test
subject d-9671
descriptions and results subject was
phonographed in absolute Darkness using
scp-7122 while being lit by an infrared
flashlight photograph was deleted
d-9671 died on the spot
test 7122.04
subject d-9672
description and results subject was
phonographed using
scp-7122 external copy of dot ano file
was created original file deleted no
change noted on subject
test 712205
subjects d-9672
d-7673-d9874 and d-9238
description and results subjects were
told to move around the room and make
casual conversation the entire group was
photographed in a wide angle using
scp-7122 no subject was phonographed
individually photograph was then deleted
no change noted on either subject
test
7122.06 subject d-9672
description and results copy of d-9672's
ano file was inserted into video editing
software the file began to visually
mimic spoken audio track no change noted
on subject
test 7122.07
subject d-9672
description and results copy of d9672's
ano file was inserted into video editing
software file began to visually mimic
spoken parts of inserted music tracks no
change noted on subject
note
scp-7122's ano files mimic spoken audio
tracks to an absolute perfect extent
were it not for the unmoving background
it would be impossible to distinguish
between an edited ano file and an
authentic video file this anomalous
effect could be of great use to the SCP
Foundation
test 7122-08
subject d-9672
description and results edited metadata
of d-9672's ano file to display a
different day of creation error message
displaying the words administrator
permission required appeared metadata
reverted back to its original state
after closing the error message
Foundation it experts have not yet been
able to bypass this effect
test 7122.09
subject d-9672
description and results deleted metadata
of d9672's ano file d-9672 instantly
ceased nearly all motor functions and
became unresponsive fmri and EEG scans
showed next to no brain activity aside
from Vinyl areas subject was described
by researchers to be in a catatonic
state
test 7122 10. subject d-9672
description and results subject brought
to stand on two legs subjects stunned on
two legs on its own subject was then
pushed lightly subject was able to
recover from push likely via a form of
muscle memory subject was pushed hard
and subsequently fell face first to the
floor fracturing its nose and jaw
d-9672 did not react to the likely
resulting physical pain
test 7122 11. subject
d-9672
description and results subject
connected to EEG and fmri scanners
respectively and subjected to a large
dose of Pain by having both femurs
fractured independently through both EEG
and fmri scans showed next to no
activity in the frontal lobe the insular
and cerebral cortex all of which are
largely important to human consciousness
and emotional response to external
stimuli upon the introduction of pain
and one waves could be measured in the
subject's brain while there was almost a
complete lack of N2 and P2 waves as soon
as the pain was inflicted both the brain
and the autonomous nervous system
reacted on a physical level by releasing
adrenaline and other hormones despite
this the scans of d-9672's brain
indicated that while it responded
somewhat normally on a physical level
the emotional and conscious component of
its perception of pain seemed to be
non-existent
note in order to retain a professional
climate Personnel are discouraged from
referring to scp-7122 as Soul killer as
fitting as that description may be
Personnel are also reminded that the
foundation does currently not know
whether such a thing as a soul even
exists
test 7122 12. subject one male
chimpanzee pant troglodyte description
and results chimpanzee was phonographed
using
scp-7122 photograph was deleted subject
died on the spot
test 7122-13
subject one female dog Golden Retriever
description and results dog was
photographed using scp-7122 photograph
was deleted subject died on the spot
test 7122-14
subject one female house cat felis
Caddis
description and results cat was
phonographed using
scp-7122 photograph was deleted subject
died on the spot test 7122-15
subject 1 male African bullfrog Pixis
cephalus and spersus description and
results frog was phonographed using
scp-7122 photograph was deleted no
change on subject
test 7122 16.
subject 1 female fire ant stolenopsis
description and results fire ant was
phonographed using
scp-7122 photograph was deleted no
change noted on subject
so the scp-7122 mostly seemed to be
limited to living beings with a certain
amount of intelligence and Consciousness
however the effects of deleting metadata
vary largely among non-humanoid species
test
7122-17 approved by site director
subject
d-7673 and d-9874
description and results both subjects
were asked to fill out a questionnaire
about themselves their personality as
well as very specific moments and
memories of their life only they knew
about
d-7673 and d-9874 were then photographed
individually using
scp-7122
d-7673's metadata was copied and deleted
afterwards with the same being done to
d9874 both entered characteristic
catatonic State as all previous subjects
the subject then had their metadata
swapped and quickly reverted back to a
rather normal State
d-7673 and d974 were subsequently asked
to answer questions about information
they had previously disclosed in the
questionnaire evaluation of their
answers showed that both now only knew
about what the biologically other should
be knowing and claimed to be that same
person both subject went on to express
extreme confusion and severe distress
stating they were in the wrong body when
asked about what happened after the
deletion of their metadata
d-7673 as well as d-9874 became
extremely agitated and would enter a
state of panic while profusely refusing
to elaborate any further about the topic
with d-9874 even becoming violent both
subjects had to be sedated and were
returned to their cells for the night
d-7673 and d-9874 went on to commit by
that same night
test 7122 18 approved by site director
subjects
d-9672 and d-7673
description and results
d-9672 who was still in a catatonic
State and recovering from the physical
effects of test 712211 had his last
metadata replaced with that of the late
d-7673
d-9672 from now on referred to as d-7673
awoke soon after in great distress
showing signs of severe psychological
trauma
d-7673 behaved erratic and started
screaming approximately half a minute
after waking up subject stopped
screaming after five minutes and died 10
minutes later from Cardiac Arrest
multiple organ failure and severely
damaged cerebral tissue all suspected to
have been caused at least in some part
by extreme psychosomatic effects of the
psychological trauma and or the numerous
transfers of metadata
addendum 7122 A1 as per order of site
director Siegler researchers are to
refrain from performing experiments
similar to test 71 2211 unless necessary
and approved by director Siegler himself
or at least two level four Personnel
this rule will stay in effect until
scp-7122's anomalous effects are
understood to a fuller extent
addendum 7122 O2
the department of intelligence has
requested utilization of
scp-7122 by field agents in order to
assure cooperation of influential
non-foundation individuals and to be
able to terminate them or hostile person
of interests if necessary the department
has also requested permission to set up
several databases with ano files of said
individuals
proposal is pending
the following document is classified at
security clearance level 4. any
unauthorized access is strictly
forbidden and will result in
disciplinary action
project balder
access to project balder is restricted
to level
47122 by order of the o5 council and the
department of intelligence personnel
with lower clearance levels are
prohibited from viewing this file
following the discovery of
scp-7122 and its anomalous effects the
department of intelligence has proposed
utilization of the camera for the
purpose of Applied influence and
liquidation of Persons of Interest
this proposal has since been granted by
the o5 council and the department of
intelligence has been provided with
personnel and funding for further
experiments
after the results of tests
7122-17 and
scp-712218 have suggested that
scp-7122 may be used to transfer a
person's Consciousness to a different
person's body including post-mortem the
o5 council ordered enhanced testing of
this effect for possible containment and
security appliances
scp-7122 has so far been used to capture
seven and terminate hostile Persons of
Interest while also having been used to
influence important non-foundation
individuals
d-class testing tests 71 22 17 and
712218 have shown severe side effects
with the transfer of metadata the
following tests seek to find a way of
negating these effects
test DOI 7122-01
subject
d-5389 and d-8376
test description subjects were told to
memorize one poem each beforehand as a
way to determine if a transfer of
Consciousness via metadata had occurred
if successful subjects were to be dosed
with medical ketamine or similar
euphoric drugs to reduce the level of
trauma seen in test 7122-17
results when asked d-class Personnel
recited each other's poem after their
metadata had been swapped thus proving
that a transfer of Consciousness had
been successful subjects expressed
discomfort about the situation but not
to such an extent as seen in d-7673 and
d9874 still the subjects became highly
agitated and refused to elaborate when
asked about what happened during the
exchange of metadata conclusion
psychedelic drugs that induce euphoric
states are feasible to reduce the
apparent traumatic effects of a transfer
of Consciousness however they do not
manage to completely negate said
problems and the long-term effects of
regular Drug Administration point to
this not being a permanent solution
still as note of test subjects had
occurred the test was deemed a success
test DOI 712202
subjects d-4381 and d1768
test description same as test DOI
712201 however subjects were placed
under general anesthesia for the
transfer of Consciousness and dosed with
heavy opiates afterwards
results d-class Personnel confirmed a
successful transfer had occurred by
reciting the correct poem just as the
participants of test DOI 712201 d-4381
and d1768 were uncomfortable with the
situation unlike test DOI 712201 subject
stated they were unable to recall
anything about the process of the
exchange of metadata still Foundation
psychologists determined that the
effects of a subconscious trauma were
present though not overly obvious
conclusion traumatic effects may be
reduced further by artificially inducing
a coma within subjects the psychological
trauma however is still a considerate
factor that is to be eradicated if
possible
test DOI 7122.03
subject Dr Dominic Martin and d-6578
forward Dr Dominic Martin is a senior
researcher of the foundation assigned to
project balder with terminal lung cancer
Dr Martin has volunteered as a test
subtech as a way to test possibilities
of extending human life by transferring
Consciousness to another healthy body Dr
Martin has declared he will not be
placed under anesthesia and initially
refused the administration of drugs in
order to properly record and document
what happens during the exchange of
metadata d-6578 is a former Foundation
employee of the administrative sector
found guilty of Espionage for a hostile
group of Interest test description as
the effects and risks of having one
subject with and one without anesthesia
are unknown the transfer occurred
without either subject being sedated as
per usual both subjects memorized a
different poem beforehand as a way of
verifying a successful transfer of
Consciousness Dr Martin was the and to
report on what he could recall according
to his own abilities
results
d-6578 who had purposely not been
informed about the Test's specific
nature beforehand awoke screaming in the
body of Dr Martin while Dr Martin while
visibly distressed remained
comparatively calm d6578 was restrained
and after reciting the correct poem to
confirm the transfer of Consciousness
sedated Dr Martin requested the
administration of anxiotic medication
this request was granted additionally Dr
Martin was also given a mild sedative
for the following two days on the third
day following the test Dr Martin resumed
documentation on his journal which he
had started beforehand in order to
document the events of the transfer of
metadata from his own perspective the
contents of his journal can be found
below
d-6578 passed away from lung cancer
three weeks after the completion of the
test but was transferred into a new
living body for interrogation after a
lack of cooperation and the failure of
conventional and advanced interrogation
methods
d-6578 was terminated by a fatal shot to
the head and transferred into another
body three hours later causing d-6578 to
give in and provide the foundation with
the requested information in exchange
for the permanent deletion of his entire
file
Journal of Dr Dominic Martin for project
balder test DOI 712203
date 2510
hello
my name is Dr Dominic Martin I am 56
years old born in Hamburg I have
volunteered to be a test subject in an
experiment about the transfer of human
consciousness into another body thinking
about it whether it's not the foundation
I'd probably go to a psychiatric board
for simply saying this sentence I should
perhaps note him that the primary goal
of this journal is not to provide an
overly scientific or clinical
documentation as it aims to document my
own subjective experiences and
observations during this test it is
hoped that certain observations will
provide the foundation with new insights
for both psychological and practical
applications
all that is currently known is that it
is possible to bring the Consciousness
or Soul if you believe that of a person
into the body of another by using a
specific anomaly the foundation has
Acquired and apparently this process
seems to have been severely traumatizing
traumatizing enough that several d-class
Personnel have committed afterwards and
every single test subject so far was
either unable or outright refused to
talk about what happened for the short
time that their soul was deleted from
our reality
so why on Earth would I volunteer for
such an experiment
the answer is quite simple
I've been a chain smoker since I was a
young man well surprise all those
warnings that smoking causes cancer
true who would have guessed I
am in a lung cancer and my time is about
to come according to doctors so since
I've been assigned to this project for
quite some time and my curiosity has
always been morbid in nature I figured I
might as well just
to be a useful asset to this program
let's just hope my mind doesn't end up
as some kind of cerebral pudding
the test will begin in two days
date 27-10
I will be restrained for the transfer
apparently the owner of my new body is a
spy of some hostile group of Interest
Who is embedded in the foundation and
they wanted to prevent him from fleeing
once he's inside my body not that my
broken body would be capable of running
anyway they see it as a kind of prison
for him convenient
convenient but cruel and my honest
opinion
I was told to memorize a poem just like
the test
s for me as a way of identifying me
after the transfer standard procedure by
now
the poem goes like this
Be not Afraid in the face of change be
courageous standing like a wall though
at first things may seem strange and
nothing familiar at all
there's a purpose in the blonde and gray
though it may still seem far you can
make it through the day no matter where
you are
I don't recognize this poem it seems
very random I wonder if one was selected
for any specific purpose
anyways it's time to begin the test
date 30-10
hello
my name is Dr Dominic Martin just he's
six years old born in Hamburg well not
really I'm actually 35 years old born in
dumb cat my body at least
the transfer of my Consciousness has
been successful there's been quite the
unpleasant experience hence why I have
requested anxious for the time being
the transfer itself well
how do I describe it I trust there was a
mild sense of unease followed by a
headache then time I'll just slow down
as both symptoms gradually became worse
I felt in intense pressure on my eyes
and inside my head accompanied by a
strange pausing sensation as if
something inside of my body was pressing
against its outside trying to force its
way through then a sudden rip there was
Darkness well not actually Darkness it
was colorful and black and white and
gray and colorless all at the same time
trying to describe it is like trying to
define the color of the mirror I saw
geometry that didn't make sense like
squares with far sides or triangles
seemingly comprised of 90 degree angles
I was in a place without space or time I
couldn't breathe because neither was
their air nor did I have a body to
breathe I was Consciousness and
unconsciousness at the same time
existing vegetating through a reality I
cannot comprehend I was in the limna
time did not seem to exist
I've been there for a few seconds or
hundreds upon hundreds of years
both felt the same after a time I cannot
Define I entered what felt like an
intense fever dream an array of
illogical and random thoughts was
sentences and Impressions infinitely
rotating
I dranked in a circle a circle that I
could not break out of I don't know if I
could even perceive that Circle or my
situation as a whole
then began the memories I lived through
them like it was my first time
experiencing them and yet they often
felt familiar like deja vu they thought
I was alive but my memories were not an
exact order I'd often jump in between
them in nonsensical ways my old memories
were true either some contradicted each
other all this causing me to question
myself and my sanity I've met people
blame you were dead or did not belong in
my perceived timeline these
contradictions however may be possible
for me to realize that none of this was
real at least I think it wasn't having
realized that I focused on the poem I
had memorized before I used it like a
mantra to try to hold on to my reality
I'm sure I could have done without it I
mean the other d-class managed it as
well but I think it helped me deal
better with my situation
maybe it made it all less traumatic in a
sense
from what I've heard I am dealing with
it much better than he does thinking
about it I'm wondering even more now if
there was a specific reason for the
selection of madhur
then during the new body was a
settling Experian I started to feel a
spinning and pulling sensation I felt
sick then like a cuddle the not reality
I was in gave away to our reality our
eyes were open but I could not yet see
everything spun around and it felt like
the insides of my body were rearranging
themselves
for what felt like days but with merely
seconds I was in terrible pain
I could feel my brain it felt like it
was burning melting
I think those symptoms may be very real
as they perfectly match those that
killed d-7673 in test 71 22 18.
I'd tasted purple I heard triangles and
squares the synesthesia took some time
to go away my theory is that those
symptoms were my Consciousness oh my
soul if you want adapting to my new body
or vice versa probably similar to the
transplantation of a new organ
series that unless the brain and body
are in a specific State they may reject
the new Consciousness in some way which
is probably what led to the known
complications of a transfer
it's a wild guess but maybe surgical
precautions like deep brain stimulation
and general anesthesia could help with
that I should maybe add that I could not
initially remember everything about the
transfer there was like waking up in the
morning where you actually have to think
about what you dreamed because you can't
really recall all of it at cost
with me since I knew what was going on
this was probably pretty easy when
compared to how they're tested subject
rarely seem to start remembering when
something triggered dead memories about
it
so amnestics may also be helpful to
minimize both physical and psychological
harm
following test DOI
712203 the recommendations of Dr Martin
have been tested and were found to be
effective Dr Martin was subsequently
administered mild amnestics at his own
request
since the transfer could now be carried
out safely the department of
intelligence was given permission by the
o5 council to initiate operation
soulmate
operation soulmate
operation soulmate is an intelligence
and Security operation carried out by
the foundation's department of
intelligence operation soulmate is aimed
at gaining intelligence about enemy
groups of Interest as well as these
secure permanent imprisonment of key
hostile agents
in preparation for operation soulmate
field agents of the foundation are
tasked with recruiting subjects fitting
the following criteria
paralyzed preferably from the neck down
living in severe poverty
from a very rural area and or a third
world country
very few or no family members
very few or no friends or similar
acquaintances
preferably no terminal illnesses
age between 12 and 55 ages outside of
the specified range need to be approved
beforehand
if a fitting subject is found field
agents are to introduce themselves as
government officials or as medical staff
of various humanitarian Aid ngos
including
and and offer the subject the
participation in an experimental medical
procedure to fully cure their disability
if subjects refused they are to be
administered amnestics and released if
subjects agreed they are taken to site
717 Jasmine Peninsula Germany and
prepared for a transfer of Consciousness
any acquaintances of the subject are to
be informed a week later that the
subject was killed in an accident
involving the ambulance vehicle they
were transported in and that the body
could not be recovered
preparations for transfer include
implantation of a deep brain stimulation
implant memorization of an individual
poem memorization of a telephone number
belonging to the foundation and limited
mental preparation about the procedure
itself subjects are not to be informed
about the existence of the foundation
under any circumstances to guarantee the
Integrity of the veil of secrecy if not
yet the case field agents are then to
use
scp-7122 to phonograph the target Person
of Interest
for the transfer subjects are to be
placed under general anesthesia inside
an interrogation cell subjects are told
beforehand that it is absolutely
integral they find a telephone and call
the specified number as soon as possible
after waking up Foundation agents are
then to track and locate the phone call
and provide instructions to link up with
Foundation Personnel or if necessary
dispatch field agents to return them to
a nearby site for further treatment
once the subject is recovered they are
to be administered amnestics and given a
cover-up story about their new life only
once it was certain that the subject
itself believes said story they are to
be released from Foundation custody
documentation about operation soulmate
can be found below
the following is a list of Persons of
Interest captured during operation
soulmate alongside additional basic
information further information such as
intelligence gained or subsequent
operations of the DOI have been excluded
from this list due to secrecy and
irrelevance to the file
operation soulmate 1. subject yaroslav
gordov 22 from Siberia Russia both legs
amputated due to diabetes lived with his
father a Russian army officer recruited
after a doctor's appointment
Person of Interest Louis Marcelo Rose 47
from France known collaborator of
Marshall Carter and dark Limited notable
incident none subject was recovered and
anesthetized
conclusion of operation operational
success
operation soulmate 2.
subject Aditya biswas 19 from Bangladesh
paralyzed from the neck down no family
lived in a disabled person's residence
from UNICEF
Person of Interest vladeslav bortzov 31
from Russia recruiter for a sarcic cult
within Russia now within Foundation
custody
notable incident none subject was
recovered and anesthetized conclusion of
operation operational success
operation soulmate 3.
subject Sanu nujin 49 from Thailand
entire family and friend group died in a
large fire at a wedding failed an
attempt left him paralyzed from neck
down recruited straight from hospital
Person of Interest Maria Munos Pereira
45 from Argentina member of the
Serpent's hand now within Foundation
custody
notable incident not subject was
recovered and anesthetized
conclusion of operation operational
success
operation soulmate 4. subject
12 from jinjang China separated from her
family at a young age paralyzed from
neck down as a result of physical
violence recruited from Huger internment
camp
Person of Interest
mid-tier operative in the chaos
Insurgency now within Foundation custody
notable incidents subjects behaved
unusual enough to arise suspicion before
being recovered subject was terminated
by a field agent to assure secrecy
conclusion of operation limited
operational success
operation soulmate 5. subject
14 from Syria family died in IED
explosion which left her paralyzed from
the waist down recruited from foster
home for disabled children
Person of Interest Ahmed Mohammed
al-hasim 52 from Iran higher ranking
Oria officer now within Foundation
custody
notable incident subject apparently was
mentally unstable before the transfer
and committed despite precautions
conclusion of operation limited
operational success
operation soulmate 6.
subject Abu bakar wachuku 35 from Niger
paralyzed from waist down after a car
crash that killed his family recruited
from hospital
Person of Interest
43 from Canada priest of the fifth
church now within Foundation custody
notable incidents subject behaved
unusual enough to arise suspicion
subject was detained interrogated and
killed by members of the fifth Church
before foundation operatives could
intervene
note as the subject was not aware about
the existence of the foundation the
information gained by the fifth church
is most likely very limited still the
operation is considered a failure
conclusion of operation operational
failure
operation soulmate seven
subject redacted for the purpose of
operational protection of foundation
operatives
Person of Interest
high-ranking member of a starkic cult
now within Foundation custody
notable incidents subject recovered
without incident subject refused
amnestics after having learned about the
foundation and offered to remain an
informant embedded within the cult after
the necessary precautions and security
measures were taken it was officially
reinserted into the cult and has since
proven to be a reliable source of Intel
conclusion of operation great
operational success
by order of the Ethics Committee
operation soulmate has been shut down
due to its inhumane and unethical nature
any similar operations are prohibited
from being conducted until further
notice
verdict of the Ethics Committee
regarding operation soulmate after
careful consideration the Ethics
Committee has come to the conclusion
that while operation's soulmate has
undoubtedly been a full success for the
SCP Foundation when it comes to
Intelligence on hostile forces in doing
so it has also committed serious
violations of human dignity
although the foundation does not
currently know whether there is such a
thing as a soul it is safe to say that
human consciousness is the closest thing
to what one would call a soul as such in
trapping a person's Consciousness with a
foreign paralyzed body defies every
known concept of human dignity
furthermore Dr Dominic Martin's Journal
together with tests 71 22 17 18 DOI 7122
1-3 and operations soul mate 5 show that
the deletion of metadata and transfer of
Consciousness are psychologically almost
unbearable for the subject and lead to
severe trauma and in some cases
even if the end always Justified the
means which in the opinion of the Ethics
Committee is not the case here the use
of such methods for advanced
interrogation would be Highly
Questionable
the success of the Department of
intelligence does prove it right which
is why project Boulder May persist
however continuation of operation's
soulmate and all further operations of
this kind are nevertheless prohibited on
the basis just mentioned
we secure we contain
we protect
from the Ethics Committee of the SCP
Foundation
okay
I think that about does it for today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
zargura
oh crap guy
the Morrigan
Rowan O'Brien
braided Peach
Dean dengus
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
segnar
your local Foundation agent
Lost Boy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
[Music]